clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic
merci abonne toi le corps humain cette
machine merveilleuse
cette mécanique de précision qui ne
laisse rien au hasard et dont chaque
mouvement est motivé par un seul
objectif la vie imaginez vos organes
voter nul à présent imaginez votre
système nerveux ce véritable chef
d'orchestre qui se démène pour que tout
se passe très exactement comme il faut
que ça se passe pour votre santé mais
aussi votre confort votre bien être et
votre sérénité
attends attends le mec qui a écrit ça
l'a jamais fait rappelle foire aux c'est
pas possible votre bien-être et votre
sérénité mon cul ouais mais justement
faut arrêter de raconter n'importe quoi
le corps humain cette machine
merveilleuse le corps humain cette
machine celle où c'est bon a été calme
et on peut y aller oui pardon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le corps humain cette machine
merveilleuse et chez nous bah ouais on
peut être les deux vous vous souvenez
n'ya pas longtemps on a parlé de
l'éternuement déjà éternuer en soi c'est
chez nous bah si attendre est en train
de parler tranquillement et tout d'un
coup on va trouver un truc plus posée
comme moyen de décrocher des crottes de
nez non bon mais il ya encore plus chez
nous et je vous avais dit qu'on en
reparlerai donc aujourd'hui on va parler
des réflexes étrange du corps humain et
vous allez voir qu'il ya moyen de faire
des jeux marrant mais là on va commencer
par le réflexe photo ce territoire avant
de rentrer dans le vif du sujet un petit
point dit qu alors un réflexe c'est une
réponse motrices involontaire brève et
instantanée de notre organisme à une
stimulation
alors après l'encyclopédie médical je
prends maintenant mon dictionnaire
étymologique
oui je suis un peu mieux
alors photo du grec fotos la lumière et
du latin sternis tard et éternuer et oui
le réflexe photo sterns août at war
c'est celui qui nous fait éternuer
quand on est au soleil en réalité c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué que ça
d'abord le réflexe photo stern août at
war tout le monde l'a pas mais ça touche
quand même une personne sur quatre
ensuite il apparaît pas juste quand il
ya du soleil sinon ce serait pénible
mais quand on passe de l'ombre au soleil
et pour finir bizarrement c'est au
niveau des yeux que ça se passe en fait
c'est une histoire de nerfs le fait de
passer brutalement de l'ombre à la
lumière ça excite le nerf optique et il
se trouve que le nerf optique il est
juste à côté du nerf trijumeau le nerf
trijumeau il énerve tout le visage et il
a plusieurs rôles différents parmi
lesquels déclencher le réflexe
d'éternuements savez quand on a un truc
qui nous gêne dans son hymne et là on a
déjà parlé et bas chez certaines
personnes
c'est là qu'ils leurs parents ont refilé
le gène responsable quand le nerf
optique et très excité comme dans ce
cas-là ça excite aussi le nerf trijumeau
qui est juste à côté et ça déclenche un
éternuement
allez on change de registre avec le
réflexe crémât ce terrien votre vie
sexuelle souffre de la routine vous
trouvé vos organes génitaux et ceux de
votre partenaire bien ennuyeux j'ai un
petit jeu pour dans une ambiance tamisée
et intime effleuré délicatement d'un
doigt l'intérieur de la cuisse
la vôtre ou celle d'une personne
consentante juste là vous observerez le
testicule où la grande lèvres du même
côté s'est levé par la magie du muscle
créé master qui se contracte en faisant
en alternance le même mouvement
de chaque côté vous pouvez ainsi jouer
aux marionnettes mais bon ça sert pas
qu'à s'amuser
les médecins s'en servent aussi pour
vérifier qu'on n'a pas une torsion
testiculaire parce que classiquement si
c'est le cas le réflexe disparaît et là
c'est plus nommant de rigoler déjà ça
fait mal et en plus c'est une urgence
petit bonus vous pouvez aussi obtenir
une réaction très satisfaisante avec une
légère stimulation ce crotales
non non stimulation scra talent ça veut
dire gratouiller le scrotum la peau des
testicules
puis je te déconseille d'aller jouer que
c'est robin et la stimulation va
entraîner une rétractation réflexe du
scrotum un petit peu comme avec les
escargots et avec cette texture un peu
peau d'éléphant qu'on les testicules
ça donne un effet absolument hilarant
qui n'a réjouir toute la salle a les
changements d'organes et passons aux
réflexes au culot cardiaque mais il a vu
des gens qui font ce geste quand ils
sont énervés
eh bien peut-être que sans le savoir il
cherche à déclencher le réflexe au culot
cardiaque au culot les yeux cardiaque le
coeur alors quel rapport
eh bien il se trouve que quand on
comprime les globes oculaires le coeur
ralentit et la tension baisse pourquoi
parce que le fait d'appuyer sur les yeux
comme ça ça stimule le nerf vague qu'on
appelle comme ça parce que il fait
tellement de trucs que son job exact est
d'ailleurs un peu fourre vague mais ibos
pour le système nerveux autonome
celui qui gère les fonctions de
l'organisme qui sont un petit peu en
mode pilote automatique genre la
digestion ou l'activité cardiaque pour
être encore plus précis ils bossent pour
le système parasympathique qui a la
capacité de ralentir le coeur mais aussi
de faire chuter la tension en dilatant
les vaisseaux sanguins
donc quand on fait ce geste là si on
garde un peu la pause on stimule le nerf
vague est en risque de faire un malaise
malaise vagal rapport au nirvana
alors attention là on rigole pas avec ça
on est d'accord que jouer avec le coeur
de quelqu'un s'est jamais une bonne idée
c'est dangereux c'est nul
[Musique]
par contre les médecins s'en servent
parfois pour calmer certaines
tachycardie et non pas tactique a redit
comme on l'entend souvent la tachycardie
c'est le coeur qui bat trop vite c'est
le coeur qui s'emballe et dans le cas de
la maladie de bouveret qui est une forme
de tachycardie particulière les médecins
peuvent utiliser cette manoeuvre pour
ralentir le coeur et faire céder la
crise mais encore une fois laisser ça
aux professionnels allez pas vous amuser
à faire ça en plus c'est dangereux pour
les yeux allez on passe à la suite avec
le réflexe philo moteur le réflexe pilot
moteur on l'appelle aussi la pilot
érection pilot les poils érection se
dresser c'est ce qu'on appelle un
réflexe archaïque c'est à dire un
réflexe qu'on a gardé mais qui nous sert
plus à grand chose si vous vous souvenez
on en avait déjà parlé dans la vidéo 5
preuve qu'on est des animaux il consiste
à activer les muscles pilot et recteur
ceux qui font se dresser les poils
quand on a froid ou quand on a peur
alors à l'époque où on avait plein de
poils dans le premier cas ça servait à
gonfler le pelage a gardé plein d'air en
dessous au niveau de la peau al
réchauffer et du coup ça nous permettait
d'avoir moins froid et dans le deuxième
cas quand un prédateur nous menaçait et
qu'on avait la trouille
ça nous permettait de gonfler notre
volume et du coup d'avoir l'air plus
impressionnants les animaux aujourd'hui
ils font toujours ça nous on a gardé le
truc aussi mais en vrai ça nous sert
plus à grand chose
on a juste la chair de poule quoi ça
tient moyens chaud et ça impressionne
panneaux des réflexes étrange le corps
il en a plein d'autres sapina mettent
parfois le signe de certaines maladies
et ça peut aider les médecins à les
diagnostiquer et parfois c'est juste des
trucs chelous c'est juste des bugs voilà
alors si vous en avez un et que vous
comprenez pas pourquoi
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer vos questions
à question dtc @ gmail point com et je
verrai ce que je préfère voilà dtc c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]